en esta reunión bilateral los temas
principales fueron la migración y la
economía habló y le pidió al presidente
baile nuevamente que ofreciera más visas
de trabajo temporal para los miles de
mexicanos y centroamericanos que están
tratando de llegar a eeuu hace unas
semanas washington se comprometió con
300.000 visas temporales de trabajo pero
méxico le pide más para contrarrestar la
crisis fronteriza para amlo esto
ayudaría a mitigar la situación no
solamente en la frontera sino llenar el
vacío de mano de obra que tiene eeuu y
ayudaría a mitigar la inflación en este
país durante la reunión donde amlo cerca
de 30 minutos y byd en tan sólo 10
minutos se trataron temas también de
cambio climático protección a
periodistas y energía entre otros
precisamente en el tema energético
amplio dijo que su país estaba
recibiendo muchos estadounidenses que
cruzaban la frontera sólo para echarle
gasolina a sus vehículos porque en
méxico el galón de gasolina era un dólar
más económico comentario que hizo que el
ambiente se tensionaron un poco sin
embargo bay dijo que a pesar de los
titulares inflados la relación entre los
dos países se mantiene sólida